this movie is brilliant you guys are
absolutely amazing especially Michelle
you are kick-ass and um you did such an
incredible job there are so many
different words to describe marijuana
what are all those words that were used
in this film I'm Canadian so marijuana
is our thing right now that's guy and
Ivan are the ones I spewed out I thought
I had some clever ones and then they go
I don't even know what I did you never
even know by by whatever it was it was a
riff and guy was throwing those at men
behind me there's something about cheese
I know I don't think I ever said you got
guy like guy enjoys creating his own
dictionary it was a lot of fun coming up
with those really cool concepts now
Henry I'm a big fan crazy rich Asians
loved it
you went from dreamy to gangster yes uh
what was it like working with Matthew
for the first time in doing that scene
and being on set was intimidating in it
was my first day on set so you know as
you do you you prepare as as much as
possible and to get on set and you
always have sort of a moment between the
actors and guy and and that's where
everything gets thrown out the window
and comes back in the ether a different
order or there's a dialogue so you
really happy on on on your feet but but
I do remember because it was such a such
a tense scene it was pretty much
yourself myself and Charlie in the
background on a table smaller than this
I do remember losing my sort of
concentration at one point and thinking
and just watching him work and I was
just like I was in I was kind of in or
and and and to be able to experience
that as a big cinema file in the best
seat possible which is right in front of
some lost they're performing something
like that you kind of have to snap back
I've got a job to do so now it was
something you know Matthew had to say
thank you because
your motivational speech I listen to it
all the time I download a comm app as
well to the listen to bedtime stories
but there was a great moment because
movie starts with you walking into a pub
and I know your career started you
walking into a bar that's true so what
has been one of the most gratifying
moments for you and your career
morning was gratifying well most for me
in my career there's been many and I
would say it's about 13 years ago I took
off for a while and didn't work because
the work I wanted to get was not coming
my way so instead of chasing what I
couldn't do
I stopped doing what I was doing for a
while and that took there's nothing came
my way for about two years and it was
sort of a nun branding time and being
that either you can learn a lesson from
that I'm saying it's also as a board
away your way or not as where you are so
I was not anywhere for two years and
then all of a sudden became you know the
new great idea is for this kind of role
and and and and that was where I learned
and remembered that it's all just
process process process I said f the
Bucks I'm going for the experience was
it mud that you came back with Lincoln
Lawyer than mud and killer Joe and mud
yeah mask my can mm-hmm are you ready to
become a superhero reverse-flash not
intentionally no yeah we'll see not a
you're not against not against him that
again in this movie with this epic cast
who is the most gentleman of them all
I'm gonna get that question
I mean they're all Jenna yeah
I you know being in a cast where you
know the majority of the cast are male
mm-hmm I you know it didn't kind of feel
the set didn't feel alpha yes me you
know it was yeah they're all very
chivalrous and lovely I mean guys a real
gent as well and he dresses immaculate
does it works in and he's wearing like a
three-piece suit and beautiful his style
is very much part of the film
congratulate ooh play it wasn't it
didn't like an alpha know everybody was
playing very powerful characters and
very secure with himself but it was not
a macho's no and there are a lot of
women behind the scenes you know I
didn't feel like the only woman and it's
and you are on guys films you are kind
of walking into a family because you
know a lot of the departments have been
working with him for 20 years so it's
got a real kind of you know it's a great
sort of camaraderie I just love that
humor you know hear over the top of
everyone going in three Guardians go-to
guy like hustling everybody together
pain no you know it's it's not it's not
poisonous and innocent you're not sort
of expect it to be it's a lot of fun and
just funny you know he's got a great
sense of humor and you know behind the
sort of intensity of some of those seems
everyone's kind of cracking up is that
whiskey but is hot guys whiskey happens
to be long range bourbon man really
cheers to Elle streaky Cheers
that's not a problem I'm drunk
holy cow you can I get those awesome
thank you so much thank you